los hombres nos distinguimos los unos a
los otros por nuestras virtudes o por
nuestros vicios son palabras que siempre
me dijo mi papá el arquitecto alfonso
gallardo
su forma de ver y de ejecutar la vida
siempre me inspiraron a ser valiente a
intentar cosas nuevas y esta aventura de
vive la vivía acompañado de mi mamá la
se le envía hermana alejandra y de mi
hermano mariano
donde vivimos a las afueras de la ciudad
en un pueblo llamado san isidro
mazatepec en una hacienda hermosa que
sin duda se convertiría nuestro lugar
favorito en todo el mundo
claro no todo era color de rosa al igual
que todas las familias tenemos problemas
riñas y una ocasión recuerdo
perfectamente que tuvimos una pelea los
y bueno yo estaba en el jardín llega mi
papá y me dice álvaro y estoy harto de
ustedes yo a su edad ya trabajaba
estudiaba dos carreras al mismo tiempo y
además hacía deportes y hacía esto y
aquello y tata
yo ni hable en la discusión y ya me tocó
el reino personalizado
pero total
inspirado en el que fue un gran charro
inclusión en el mundo del polo
posteriormente estuve en la selección
jalisco de atletismo y ya en mis ratos
libres de iva que a la bici a la moto
al fly board y pude comprobar en estos
19 años lo satisfactorio que es forjar
nuestras virtudes en la vida
pero también pude comprobar lo rápido
que estas se pueden esfumar cuando a los
hombres le expresar en sus vicios ante
sus virtudes
el 8 de diciembre del 2013
yo estaba con mi mamá haciendo unas
compras y nunca se me va a olvidar las
palabras que salieron de su boca
contestó una llamada en la cual decía
alejandra porque estás gritando
alejandra deja de gritar que está
pasando a ver vamos para allá
y el camino que usó al parir a nuestra
casa
se convertirá en un calvario
recibimos una llamada más
en la cual mi hermana decía por favor
mamá no vengan a la hacienda los están
esperando saben que vienen en el coche
de álvaro que tú traes un chaleco color
café que álvaro viene vestido de azul
por favor mamá no vengan a la casa
y tuvimos que tomar la decisión de dejar
el incertidumbre
a mi papá ya mi hermana
al llegar a casa de mis abuelos nos
enteramos que cuatro hombres armados
habían irrumpido en nuestra casa
intentamos secuestrar a mi hermana
alejandra
afortunadamente no se la lograron llevar
pero como todas las fortunas está tuvo
un precio altísimo
el cual se cobraron asesinando a mi papá
en su habitación
en ese momento supe que mi vida jamás
volvería a ser la misma que ese domingo
me levanté siendo uno y que me iba a
apostar siendo completamente otro
que el sueño que por 19 años llame vida
rápidamente se convertiría en una
pesadilla de la cual me quería despertar
tuvimos que tomar decisiones las más
difíciles que nos tocó tomar como
familia en esas semanas la primera de
ellas era que mi hermana alejandra tenía
que abandonar el país ya que teníamos
miedo a que tomaran alguna represalia
contra ella
mi hermano mariano como el más grande de
la casa era lógico que tenía que empezar
su camino de vida solo
quien más me dolió sin duda fue mi mamá
porque ella no solo perdió a su esposo
perdió al padre de sus hijos y perdió
ese hombre que la hizo sentir segura
durante 30 años de relación
así que yo también tenía que empezar a
tomar decisiones en mi vida y ese
momento fue cuando me sentía el hombre
más solo del mundo
entonces tuve que preguntarme tres
caminos
el primer camino era el de deprimir más
es decir porque a mí porque a nosotros
llorar y sufrir así como en la imagen
literal
el segundo camino sin duda era el más
fácil el más sencillo
rodearme de la gente de fiesta tomar y
hasta desmayarme y olvidar y por qué no
en este país es muy fácil entrar un
negocio que te dé mucha lana y muy
rápido y pues en la reina del sur' pudo
pues se iba a tener aquí a su rey
pero pues no le tenemos que decir que a
la reina todavía tenemos un camino más
en el tercer camino
recordé quién soy
de dónde vengo
el tercer camino era del hombre que
siempre quise ser ese hombre que dios y
mi papá quieren que sea el camino más
largo sí que era el camino más difícil
sí
pero yo sabía
que por cada momento que trabajara hoy
lo iba a cobrar con muchas recompensas
el día de mañana
y total ya no sabía quién era hoy mucho
menos sabía quién iba a ser el día de
mañana
entonces tome mi maleta y emprendí mi
primer viaje solo viaje al sur del país
a los estados de oaxaca y de chiapas
triste solo con tantos problemas con la
soledad que es la mejor amiga pero
también es la más cabrona porque es la
que teme es la que me enseñó todos mis
problemas y que en este viaje les pueden
contar solución y lo que empezó como una
terapia para poder sanar el duelo tras
la muerte de mi papá
inesperadamente se convirtió en un blog
de viajes hoy llamado indiana vallarlo
en el cual comparto mi pasión de viajar
por méxico en el cual se empezaron a
sumar varios medios de comunicación
entre ellos revistas periódicos que
apoyaban mi idea de poder inspirar a más
jóvenes a salir de sus problemas de esa
burbuja de esa rutina que tanto nos
puede llegar a agobiar
que ya sea a 40 minutos de la ciudad o
de punta norte a punta sur del país la
respuesta está en nosotros mismos
nosotros somos la respuesta que se
atrevan a mirar ya viajar por méxico
los sueños se empezaban a ser tangibles
uno de ellos que con mucho gusto se los
comparto es el regalo más grande que yo
me estoy dando en la vida
y es que yo me estoy pagando mi carrera
aquí en universidad panamericana
me urge
no graduarme tener hijos para poderlos
molestar como se quejen y decirles wey
cállate o sea difícil pagarte la
universidad saques estudiar no como si
estuviera tanto pero total lo que yo
quiero es que los jóvenes al igual que
yo sepan que nada es imposible que si
sabemos trabajar y buscar los medios
adecuados podemos convertirnos en esa
mujer o ese hombre que tanto quiere ser
todos los días le doy gracias a dios y
en mi ángel en el cielo por darme la
energía y la fuerza de seguir en ese
tercer camino
por qué
porque yo creo fielmente en que ya sea
una o mil personas a las que pueda
llegar en mi blog no se ve pero con que
pueda llegar en alguna de ellas como una
guía de viajes
o como un ejemplo de vida no sé tampoco
es lo que más alegría y satisfacción me
da
han pasado ya cinco años
y aunque yo no pedí
estar en este camino aunque yo no pedí
ser feliz hoy me siento el hombre más
feliz del mundo
porque en el peor momento decidí ser
capitán de mi vida decidí ser el hombre
que siempre quise ser ese hombre que
dios y mi papá quieren que sea que hoy y
mañana voy a seguir trabajando para
hacerlo yo no pedí ser feliz y lo soy
esta aplauso es para ustedes mariana no
hay más